good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
studying today is SCP 2774 the object
class
Keter special containment procedures all
instances of a CP 2774 are to be
destroyed upon recovering webcrawler ao3
g32
has been set to monitor and scan all
forms of online visual media for SCP
2774 a and alert recovery teams upon
detection teams are assigned to monitor
internet and live television for SCP
2774 a if detected recovery teams are to
be dispatched immediately any personnel
who are exposed to an instance of
scp-2107 t for more than 5 seconds are
to be issued Class C amnestics and
temporarily relocated to site 116 due to
the nature of SCP 2774 it is recommended
that researchers assigned to a CP 2774
have some form of deuteron obeah
colloquially referred to as red green
colorblindness recovery teams are
working to recover those affected by a
CP 2774 and relocate them to site 116 to
test for a possible cure until one is
discovered site 116 will serve as a
permanent residency for all affected
persons read addendum alpha approval for
testing subjects in site 116 must come
from the ethics committee and site
overseer dr. Martin subjects kept its
site 116 are to maintain limited to no
contact with personnel unless approved
by the proper parties subjects captain
site 116 are to be allowed two hours a
day of social interaction with other
subjects
thirty minutes will be designated to the
following breakfast lunch courtyard and
dinner subjects are not to be allowed to
wander outside of the designated social
areas or stay in groups larger than five
subjects will be contained in Euclid
level humanoid containment cells as of
October 15th 2010 subjects are not to
have social interaction of any kind
in addition subjects must not leave
their cells until further notice
description SCP 2774 is any medium which
contains SCP 2774 a SCP 2774 a is a
mimetic image of an unknown humanoid
entity presumably wearing a sloth
costume Effects of viewing as CP 2774
set in between 40 to 100 hours after
exposure to SCP 2774 a those affected
will begin to lose the ability to use
cognitive functions or make higher-level
decisions except for a period lasting
around 150 seconds every 24 hours this
period occurs randomly SCP 2774 a
manifests itself in various forms of
non-live media including movies
television magazines and in some cases
personally recorded videos or pictures
SCP 2774 a is typically located in the
background of whatever media it appears
in to date there have been no instances
of scp-2107 t 4 on the internet a single
incident in northern canada where a CP
2774 a appeared on live local television
resulted in the relocation of over 4,000
people to site 116 the image only
retains its anomalous properties if the
image contains hues of red or green
therefore those with Duden arabiya or
other forms of colorblindness are not
affected by SCP 2774
SCP 2774 a is believed to possess
memetic properties that are enhanced
based on the number of people that
effects manifestations of SCP 2774 a
appear to become more frequent as the
number of living victims increases after
the implementation of protocol xxj nine
reports of manifestation dropped
significantly tests show that including
the colorblind SCP 2774 does not affect
the majority of people who view it it is
estimated that under 40% of those
exposed to SCP 2774 are actually
affected this percentage is also
directly affected by the number of
living SCP 2774 a victim's when subjects
to SCP 2774 a's effect
victims appear to move normally based on
muscle memory al biet with slowed
reaction times they are very passive and
compliant with personnel willing to
answer basic questions and follow
commands though they display a lack of
emotion while they appear conscious
victims cannot control their actions in
any way during this time victims
upon entering their 150 seconds of
lucidity are often highly agitated and
fearful victims may act irrationally
while lucid those affected report
complete memory of time spent without
cognitive function but no ability to
comprehend their actions or affect them
in any way upon initial realization of
regained cognitive abilities most
expressed thread upon realizing the
permanence of their situation in
numerous instances that was affected by
SCP 2774 report observing a CP 2774 8
while their body is acting autonomously
perception of reality appears to be lost
during that time subjects are to be
considered unstable when conscious and
are to be approached with care
not to be approached at anytime those
who have been resettled at site 116 have
displayed an affinity to SCP 2774 a art
literature and effigies of SCP 2774 a
can commonly be found hoarded in the
corners of the subjects rooms all
objects are presumed to have been
created while unconscious these objects
are commonly traded between subjects
during free hours any such items are to
be removed and incinerated and their
creators terminated along with any
subjects seen emulating a CP 2774 a
[Music]
recorded interview log 27 dr. Clark
Chung conducted the following interview
with subject 866 David On June 11th 2010
upon confirming lucidity if you help
answer a few questions we can come
closer to fixing you are you ready
just hurry since we have limited time
could you tell us what exactly you
experienced when you're not in control
yeah yeah well I guess it's like this
it's like you're being turned around and
you're in the passenger seat alright
except your arms and legs are strapped
down so that you can't move you can't
feel anything in your body
either the worst part is that you can't
hold the thought for more than five
seconds but we can continue tomorrow if
you'd like is fine it I just want to
enjoy being able to control myself of it
before I lose it when you're stuck in
there
in your own head just want to scream you
can't you try for hours and hours moving
on a leg make a sound
it won't happen you can't even control
when you breathe and then the
hallucinations salaah I just subject 866
looks towards the guards standing on
each side of dr. Chung then checks the
clock subject 866 begins to shake
subject 866 reluctantly lunges towards
the guard to dr. Chung's right subject
866 is terminated immediately following
contact dr. Chung exits the room
[Music]
following this interview the clock in
the site 1:16 interview room has been
removed
record an interview log 30 dr. Clark
Chung conducted the following interview
with subject 74 44 clawed on October 1st
2010 upon confirming lucidity now we
just have a few on office please just
kill us is the only way to stop eight
there's just no point anymore stop one
that's sloth
I don't know what it is the first few
days of you stuck on this she'll tell me
once two three times
no okay but for a week I saw you just
see everywhere nowhere is safe
in the color of my eyes just staring I
don't know
please could you continue on about this
sloth if if I do it's gonna punish me
for this one there's lots never talks
never sense a word a finger like I need
to be I need to act like it sort of
leave me alone
everyone knows it wants us help
it knows have you done to it can see it
even when I'm awake I can see you're
watching us right now run right behind
you he's just sitting there looking
right at me
what when I sleep makes me open my eyes
sometimes we control our bodies woman
either
okay can I just watch it it's there
isn't more line and then
it's faster screaming I don't cry or
yell for help
Oh at this point in time subject seventy
444 becomes unresponsive collapsing onto
the desk
Lord Lord are you alright Medical we
need assistance medical teams rush into
the room it was determined to be a
return to previous cognitive state
[Music]
approximately four hours after the
interview dr. Chung filed for immediate
termination of subjects seventy 444 this
request was approved on October 4th 2010
recorded interview log 32 dr. Clark
Chung conducted the following interview
with subject 9225 Jason on October 5th
2010 upon confirming lucidity hello
Jason
the sooner we can fix you and everyone
else we don't have much time
did you please answer the following
questions the subject 9225 nods quickly
great now others have mentioned
hallucinations while incapacitated can
you tell us what kind of other two
nations you experienced there's a
everyone okay and they're walking around
like zombies like I do I see the sloth
the thing with the sloths costumes it
walks around and it controls people
small things like basic tasks you know
it's testing wanted to do I don't know
if it's a loose ination what kind of
things does it make you do
okay well it usually just it controls us
but it's an Avenue more and more every
time more people come here it makes us
do more I think that soon it would make
us do a lot more in the beginning of
which is new things like moving in all
arm or a leg or something like that
last time it made us fight remember that
a few days ago that wasn't in doing it I
can see it
twisting though it's been changing to
becoming darker or solid like after the
time is subject 9225 jerks his head back
dr. Chung jumped back in his chair as
subject 9225 convulses and security
rushes into the room subject 9225 looks
back to dr. Chung with a blank
expression
following this interview additional
security was prescribed to site 116 as
well as a letter to the ethics committee
requesting implementation of procedure
xxp 9 the request was accepted two days
after it was sent see addendum alpha
addendum alpha level 3 clearance
required
addendum procedure XX j 9 following the
recorded interview log 32 my team and I
have drafted protocol x XP 9 in order to
help container CP 2774 a we will begin
by pruning the current population of
site 1/16 from approximately 6,400
subjects to 200 by this time next month
termination will be carried out by site
1/16 staff by method of lethal injection
schedules for termination will be sent
to all personnel in addition to this
task forces in charge of controlling a
CP 2774 off site have been instructed to
terminate anyone exposed instead of
transporting them here this procedure
has been approved by the necessary
parties and will begin within the week
if you are on site and listening to this
you're probably going to have to take
part in this class am-ness ticks will be
available after your duties are done if
you so choose keep in mind the state of
suffering these people are in this is as
much for their benefit as it is ours
this is doctor Clark Cheung signing off
okay I think that about does it for
today thank you all for listening if
indeed you still are
and you were all dismissed goodbye I
[Music]
would like to give a special thank you
to the reclusive extrovert geum's Sabah
Kathryn June's Pablo ice 917 Karim a la
shmoop
Justin de Curie kuma trevor w peg white
crew n je vous Jack Bryson Bailey my
archive curator neck tie verbal
Burlington the cot ond courts 563 if you
would like a special thank you at the
end of each of my videos on some other
cool stuff as well visit patreon.com
forward slash the Volgin thank you
[Music]
you